if you would estimate how many messages
you'd get in a week or whatever oh it's
[Music]
absolutely 5 000 messages a day
email yourself myself it was just what I
thought was the right thing to do it's
actually funny I interviewed uh kabi
Lama the world's second biggest tick
tocker and I asked him how he reached
his manager and he watched his manager
watch Twitch he sent him 100 DMS and
lastly the manager responded so I mean
it definitely works you know tenacity
matters the tact when you're trying to
reach someone matters as well some
people can come off incredibly entitled
can come off incredibly unsettling but
there are many people who will reach out
40 times and I'm incredibly comfortable
with it because I can sense the tenacity
balance it's a humble hunger versus an
anxious expectation